Speaker 1: Let's try Luke from Indiana.
Luke from Indiana.
Please save us.
Luke, I can hear you sort of what's going
on?
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Well, how's it going, it's going
well.
Basically, what I want to talk about is a
lot of people that don't live in rural areas
don't understand truly how deep the urban
rural divide is.
Yeah.
With the vaccinations, we've been hanging
out about 40 percent in Indiana for weeks
now, right.
And it's just not going up.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, I actually went
to Indiana a couple of years ago and I was
in rural northern Indiana.
So it was like Goshen.
Speaker 2: And I really I'm about I'm about
an hour west that I'm in Valparaiso.
Speaker 1: OK, yeah.
It was like Goshen and Shipshewana and all
these little little places and spending some
time there.
I like of course, all those people voted for
Trump.
You drive around, all you see is Amish folks
shooting ranges and evangelical churches.
If that's what you grow up around and you're
not exposed to different types of people,
you're not exposed to.
Hey, there's a whole alternative view here
of empiricism and science.
Of course, abortion and guns are the most
important issues.
And of course, you voted for Donald Trump,
even if half the stuff he says isn't even
is isn't isn't is not even true and sincere.
So, yeah, I think that a lot of people who
just spend their time in cities, they don't
get how it gets to this point in the rural
parts of the country.
And I think it would be useful for people
to spend some time there and better understand
how it happens, as you're pointing out.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah.
And I think a lot of the problem, too, is
a lot of the people here, like you said, they
grew up in that scenario.
Yeah.
And they don't feel like anyone's trying to
reach out and change their mind at all, like.
Right.
I live in one of the more outside of Indianapolis.
It's one of the more liberal places in Indiana
because we have a steel mill about.
Forty minutes away, that's one of the biggest
employers in the area, right, but even that
a lot of those people voted for Trump just
because they don't think that any of the Democrats
are doing anything to reach out to them, they
feel pretty alienated.
Right.
And a lot of them care about economics more
than anything, but.
Yeah, no one's reaching out to you, you can't
expect them to change, I don't think.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think it's a great starting
point.
It would
be great from people that are more urban on
the left to spend some time in these areas
to just start understanding what's going on.
I appreciate you bringing that
point up.
Speaker 2: Of course.
Speaker 1: All right, Luke from Indiana, thank
you very much.
An almost unblemished set of phone calls today
with just one dropped
call and otherwise almost perfect audio.
People getting to questions.
Beautiful, beautiful thing.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to speak to everybody
who's holding.
I see about 30 other people holding.
We will take calls again.
And I hope to speak to you
the next time